police across the country now hunting an
Ohio man who recorded himself killing a
stranger he then posted the attack on
Facebook 37 year-old Stephen Stephens is
accused of shooting Robert Godwin senior
on Sunday in Cleveland the victim was
apparently targeted random moments later
Stephens discussed the shooting on
Facebook live the videos remained online
for about two hours prompting outrage
against Facebook the social media giant
called the shooting a horrific crime it
is reviewing how violent content is
reported the company admitted quote we
need we know we need to do better
community members gathered yesterday at
the scene of the shooting to pay tribute
to Robert Godwin Dean Reynolds is at
Cleveland City Hall with what Stephens
told a fraternity brother before the
shooting Dean good morning good morning
the suspect Steve Stevens has now been
charged with aggravated murder and
authorities are frantically looking for
him but they concede he could be almost
anywhere this is what we would consider
a national search investigators are
chasing down dozens of leads on Monday
afternoon police in Philadelphia
received calls about potential sightings
but they did not materialize Cleveland
Police and the FBI recovered weapons
during searches of homes and locations
Stevens may have had access to our same
signal maintained in one of the videos
Stevens mentions his fraternity Omega
Syfy do you think he's still alive
I pray yes some of his fraternity
brothers are urging Stevens to turn
himself in jason clockman says he called
Stevens after seeing his first Facebook
post just before the shooting on Sunday
he said Stevens was apologizing for
letting down the fraternity Jason if he
if he were watching this what would you
tell him right now I would tell him you
know come back come in peacefully
regardless of the accident you did we
have your best interests at heart but
don't go out harm any more people the
hardest part that we had since yesterday
was reconciling who is this person that
we see on Facebook I'm forced to believe
it because I'm
and with my own eyes on Monday the
Cleveland community remembered Godwin at
the place where he was shot he was my
rock Angela small is the mother of God
wins two youngest children every time I
was just wanted to give up he was always
there to pick me up every time I felt
like everything was against me he was
there he was there
police police from at least five states
are now involved in the manhunt as well
as the FBI and several other federal
agencies a $50,000 reward is also being
offered for information leading to the
arrest of the man who is now on the
FBI's most wanted list
Norah all right Thank You Dean